[Music]
all right so president Trump he hit the
road today to outline details of his tax
plan and how it's gonna impact you and
your families let's take a look this is
a once-in-a-generation opportunity and I
guess it's probably something I could
say that I'm very good at I've been
waiting for this for a long time we're
going to cut taxes for the middle class
make the tax code simpler and more fair
for everyday Americans and we are going
to bring back the jobs and wealth that
have left our country and most people
thought left our country for good we
want tax reform that is pro-growth
pro-jobs pro worker pro-family and yes
tax reform that is pro-american now
basically the president he's following
through on what he promised you on the
campaign trail now here's what the
president outlined today he's going to
consolidate the seven current brackets
to just three brackets with new rates
1225 and 35% he's gonna double the
standard deduction and if you're single
well you're not gonna pay taxes on the
first $12,000 you make if you're married
that increases to $24,000 the child tax
credit that also will be expanded and he
will repeal the alternative minimum tax
and he will end the death tax double
taxation now the corporate rate will be
lowered to 20 percent and he wants to
create a 25% pass-through tax rate which
is going to help small business owners
he's also calling for a very low
repatriation tax and that's a tax rate
for multinational corporations that
targets money directly that's parked
overseas because of the high taxation
and regulation here and that allows
these multinationals to bring trillions
back to the American economy so let me
explain the corporate side of tax reform
is so very important and here's why when
businesses face higher taxes it gets
passed on to you the customers
corporations don't pay taxes now if
President Trump's plan is approved all
these companies will have billions of
dollars if not more of extra money then
I got to put it
their bank account guess what they're
going to do they're gonna invest capital
of manufacturing centers and factories
which will create jobs for the millions
of Forgotten men and women in this
country that's what we need that's what
we want that's what many of you voted
for and to add to that the house freedom
caucus they are now supporting the
president's plan so basically everything
that the president is proposing is
designed to help grow the economy and
the only thing I would add to the plan
personally give a tax cut across the
board let everybody have it and in many
ways it's a lot like what President
Reagan did in the 1980s President Reagan
he created the blueprint for economic
success and it all adds up here are the
facts Reagan he slashed over the course
of his presidency the top marginal rate
from seventy to twenty eight percent as
a result economic growth exploded for
example in 1984 GDP growth get this hit
seven point three percent well Barack
Obama didn't reach three percent in a
single year of his presidency the only
president in history not to do that
twenty million jobs were created under
Reagan after the 82 recession revenues
to the government doubled by cutting
taxes and America it saw the longest
period of peacetime economic growth in
history to that point and if Americans
if you want more proof that works I'll
just take a look at what happened when
John F Kennedy a Democrat believe it or
not he cut the top marginal rate from
ninety-one percent to 77 percent
same thing millions of jobs created GDP
growth soared but today the left
predictably all they want to do despite
all the tax cuts that the president's
proposing for the middle class and
corporations and small businesses they
do what they always do write to the
playbook let's play class warfare take a
look under this plan the wealthiest
Americans and wealthiest corporations
make out like bandits while middle-class
Americans are left holding the bag what
has been released today makes a total
mockery out of the president's pledge
that he wanted tax relief to be for the
working class
it wouldn't be for the wealthy it's a
swindle of the American people selling
the same blueprint that failed
trickle-down back Bush tax cuts for the
rich did that did not create jobs and
only increase the deficit same boring
talking points and then you got the
mainstream media an expansion of the
Democratic Party all they did was echo
those talking points watch listen to
this as you look at this plan are those
cuts imbalanced favoring the wealthy
over the working class president says
this plan will provide little benefit
for people of wealth like himself is
that true in a word no the majority of
this tax plan the benefits are going to
go to the wealthy so if he's worth as he
says ten billion dollars and he doesn't
have to pay any tax on his estate that
would be an enormous bonanza for him and
other very wealthy people right
absolutely
you can cut taxes on people who are
lower income but it's peanuts and their
wallet compared to the windfall that
that would be for the wealthy they're
not even mentioning some of the easiest
stuff that benefits the wealthy and that
is by considered by everyone to be
essentially unfair that people like
hedge fund managers and very wealthy
investment professionals pay such a low
tax rate a good point hiding they're
just wrong they don't know what they're
talking about now the Trump hating
Washington Post perfect example they
attack the president's tax plan look at
the headline what it says GOP proposes
deep tax cuts provides few details on
how to pay for them now this is what the
liberal press and people on the Left
will never ever understand in spite of
Reagan and Kennedy success the idea it's
not a zero-sum game you want to grow the
economy and if you do that well those
people out of work and in poverty and on
food stamps they'll have jobs and stop
taking handouts and they'll start paying
taxes in other words you incentivize
people to work and pay taxes you create
an environment that's growth oriented
for everybody
Democrats the media they just play class
warfare they've been doing it for
decades now you got to remember this
Democrats and the mainstream Left
establishment media they're not telling
you that under present
Obama they'll never tell you this 13
million more Americans were on food
stamps eight million more Americans were
put in poverty 95 million Americans were
out of the labor force lowest labor
participation rate since the 70s and the
worst economic recovery since the 40s
lowest homeownership rate in 51 years
and by the way President Obama
accumulated more debt than every other
president before him combined great job
President Obama now they also don't want
you to know that here's the facts the
rich that they hate so much the top 1%
of wage earners in America according to
the IRS they pay thirty nine point five
percent of all federal income taxes top
ten percent wage earners they pay 70
point nine percent of personal income
taxes so it sounds like the rich are
paying their fair share to me now the
bottom 50% of wage earners they pay 2.8
percent combined and we can't forget 35
percent of tax filers pay nothing zero
federal income tax and under President
Trump's plan they'll even pay less so my
advice to the GOP is very simple stay
the course
follow the reagan the kennedy models and
stick to the plan that the president is
proposing